hey guys I'm back this is gonna be a
quick stream I have one challenge
someone someone just messaged me uh can
i play you
I said challenge me and he challenged me
so I'll play this guy Kapoor's a good
luck have fun and let's play e4 let's be
aggressive this game
now he said are you going to stream
hopefully the stream is live Nathan is
here that's a good sign it should be
five
take the night rule is if they don't
play 94 you just take the nights and
then I'll play this like a Grand Prix
h5 he plays us so quickly it's like it's
preparation
let's just play d3 let's be solid
people can touch can challenge me to
anytime control I'm not going to be
picky I'm just gonna follow the fate of
of Siri so I mean blitz is nice people
challenge me to blitz I'll be able to
play more games but whatever people want
play Queenie one the special mundi seven
has no future
or does it does you want to play this
no future
moobot explaining what's going on thanks
to Nathan thanks for the host Nathan my
day four is very thematic let's just
play
and then c4 is very thematic
position is filled with thematic ideas
b3 is thematic to defend the night and
prepare c4
if c4 happens this is positional heaven
for lights
because blacks pieces are just so sad
I think blacks should have played see
for the position widths will be
difficult now I'm draw until like this
mover this move because he can't really
defend a pawn he's also just blundered a
queen which is a nice gift
tough game
that's the magic of the Grand Prix
attack
guy I recommend playing 94 here it's a
more challenging move thank you
thanks for the follow
hello to more people hello how's the
horsie move and hello Camel Clutch er I
haven't seen Camel Clutch her around in
a while I have one pending challenge
I'll just continue to accept - the only
challenge playing a patron the little
Annie
adderall luck have fun
let's play let's play d5
opening that I've been wanting to play
for a while
let's find out six first
and play a semi Slav Bishop f4 I wanted
to play a cambridge spring so you can't
play the Cambridge Springs against
Bishop f4 only against Bishop g5 usually
Bishop f4 is as a mistake because the
bishop gets hit in many lines with
Knight d5 although Peter Svidler I don't
think that's a real Peter Svidler but
hello
okay so 95 is one option b5 is one
option
so attractive
I wasn't gonna play a London this game
though maybe he was signaling no he was
he was not signaling and he was gonna
play the London don't play b5 all of
these moves are very thematic moves if I
upload this to YouTube I might just use
some version of thematic in the title
playing thematic chess or something I
could take the bishop yeah let's get the
bishop here and I'll put the bishop on
b7 and I'll play a six I don't have a
pawn chain and I'll have two bishops
and I have an extra pawn
life is so good right now
Peter Svidler you saw me at k-6
nationals
I'm gonna see the real Peter Svidler in
in just a few days he's coming to st.
Louis to do Russian commentary
can be very exciting
thanks for the comment Samsonite 220
and Oliver cab hello
call hello
okay 95
it's point 97
I would be happy with trades
trades are about to happen but if I take
the night he takes my bishop and then he
attacks my rook
so I guess we'll trade bishops improve
my knight
I think the plan is to put the Queen on
d6 put the rock on d8 because this is a
nice fitted pawn
set
trade more queen g5 let's just trade
everything
the e-file opens like he takes on d5 and
his rook would be able to access you one
okay I'll play rook d8 I think my bishop
belongs on f6 the target the pawn
pons
have any we cons iPods are so solid
this is three plus two it is rated
take the slightly seriously
hey Izzy nation chess my first and one
of my most loyal subscribers ten months
in a row wow it's about to be like a
year anniversary since I started
streaming consistently
once we hit October it'll
you some kind of one-year anniversary
but it's not like an official one-year
anniversary because my first ever stream
was maybe two years three years ago
where I was just kind of playing around
but last October I started streaming and
znation chests the first subscriber
happy birthday znation chess is actually
your birthday
because you're on Eastern Time
it's another free pond
and just gave me a free partner
in chesses birthday
nice
smaller free pawn because he's winning
the bishop
but we're treating more I can't complain
with that
okay now I have to demonstrate some kind
of endgame technique
if I play rook to you he plays this and
then this is weak maybe I do this defend
let's fire up to it
it I'll do some kind of platinum I'll
play Queen d6
could even consider Brooke d6
in some cases
the faculty Queen d6 he plays this he's
gonna win the pawn
I could play queen aids
remove
let's play route d6 everything's
defended in this position literally
everything this defends this defends
this defends this
this is undefended so is this
okay so he really wants to win the pawn
considering just going for the kill but
I would blunder Queen b8 so let's just
be safe
defending the upon another time
and very soon I would like to create a
passed pawn on the queenside
and somehow achieve back rank mates
or just or just flag my opponent
okay so Ricki one
I don't think there's a threat
screen beards
so let's play rookie six
seven
I blundered upon oops
it's only the first or no it's the
second game
- blunder
okay well I'm making life more
challenging for myself northrend some
cheapo
please don't see it
thought he's not threatening to take so
I can do this
if we wrote a k-6 I made in one
meanwhile I just want to push
or checkmates
not the best technique good game little
Annie saying gah GG
yeah
him or her
anyway hello to more people
hello morrison seed hello Jimmy Ackerman
eirick did have a smile on the open file
okay
well I was playing RR aive raised
whatever-your-name-is
game now I have 9 pending challenges now
I have to use Siri
give me a random number between 1 and 11
it's five okay this time I'll count in
Russian a Dean dois three-shot Irie
I forgot five is it p @ p OTT
five in Russian but I can translate into
Spanish Mandarin Chinese French and a
few others
how do you say five in Mandarin Chinese
what
let's fire London I know very little
Russian I know basic chess words and I
mean I know more than Siri so that's
something
96
member there's some move order tricks I
think
yeah there's some move order tricks
let's see if we go into anything
interesting
thanks for the follow what's your name
Dragoon so this is a first move order
trick it's important to play ninety two
and not Knight f3 if 9 f3 there would be
Queen b6 and it's important too
the rook so it doesn't get trapped in
certain lines but in this line okay we
transpose into some kind of mainline we
say hi to chess Bay you say hi to Joker
teeth and J Brand is there static oh no
it could be is there interference with
my phone because it was doing that last
time on my phone on the floor maybe that
will help Bishop e7 is a tricky move
but yeah Bishop e7 he's threatening that
h5 so I'm going to play h3
chespin likes my pick of the giant king
well now I need my phone back to show
the kick unless
my Instagram yeah I was just taking a
walk yesterday and it was like right
before a sunset or during sunset and the
light was great
there's a giant chess piece just sitting
there chess bay with the link
always delivering
it is slightly modified in in Lightroom
though I had to boost up the contrast
and the dynamic range
but yeah it's been in a while before
that since I posted on Instagram but
probably the next like several days I'll
be posting more because there's about to
be a boatload of super GM's coming to
st. Louis and I'll be taking pictures of
them most likely okay so let's just
Castle and now I just want to do London
stuff improve the night's
maybe go for a four at some point
what do I take with I'll take with pawn
having a pawn on e5
I'm expecting 97 and then I can provoke
g6
Yates this is very very typical London
stuff
and usually take some effort to win
these positions
actually one difference here I can't I
don't have access to h3 which is useful
in some other lines magista thanks for
following I did not play title Tuesday I
forgot it was the first Tuesday of the
month um next time I have to plan ahead
except the next several months I'll be
teaching on Tuesdays I don't know when
my next title Tuesday is going to be
I really don't want to do this but I'm
going for Queen h6 he's going to play
Rocky eight then I played Bishop H to
Bishop f8 me not for Bishop g7 Knight f3
it's a little ugly but
I guess it's possible
Peter Svidler I am streaming for the
next three days at least I finally got
around to making a schedule
oh thanks Jess pay I just saw your
comment I do appreciate that but I do
have a schedule it's updated presumably
a stream tomorrow and the next day and
the next day after that
so I might just end up planning just
like a few days ahead rather than trying
to map a full week out is that sometimes
difficult
I'm streaming late because my workday
ended it at 9:00 p.m. and I had to get
food I had to calm down
I'd some stressful relief tea got a new
brand of tea at Whole Foods which has
relieved the stress at least temporarily
this is playing chess and streaming is
one way to get the stress back
by taking part in the rapid shield
should look up Lily chess tournament
calendar because I'm not sure yeah I
might be I might be missing like some
important tournaments or something I'm
not sponsored by anything yet
if I'm promoting a product it's because
I truly like the product and not because
of a sponsorship if at some point I do
get sponsored I will probably have a
disclaimer
a kind of tea it's literally called like
stress relief tea
I forget it was from Whole Foods you can
get them on Amazon anything they sell in
Whole Foods I think you can go on Amazon
except like the fresh stuff
not entirely sure
I think there is lavender in it it was
like honey lavender stress relief but
it's long gone
for now
sponsored by the st. Louis chess club
this dream is not sponsored by by
anything except for me and by whoever
cheers I guess
Jack Z Jack see were you the one sharing
the dubrovsky links
I think yeah I at some point I clicked
on one of the links and you like one of
the hanging musicians was really
interesting I do appreciate you sharing
links sometimes they're hard to click on
during stream though
okay let's go 41
you
there's a 9:00 a.m. tournament
make up that early
would have just fall asleep now
I get about nine hours of sleep
Knight g5 okay let me think
ninety-five
is a bad move
this defended let's play Queen D for
this is potentially going to be a very
long grind
I think the long-term plan is to somehow
get a pawn to f4 King to H 1 root 2 G 1
and someday play G for black clearly
wants to expand on the Queen side
play 91
mr. Tam fan thanks for the follow
okay I'm gonna try and focus on the game
because it's it's
about to be a time scramble at least for
my opponents
be known for me play the Grob thanks for
the follow
trade Queens probably not because I
would want the night to come to D for
the King to come to h1 and I'll just
continue with
start with 903
it still takes a while for black to
breakthrough on the queenside
but he is trying let's start with my tea
for attacking the pawn Queen e7 or
rookie 7 or Riki 8 will be played or
none of those moves
it's another free pawn
in my sack thanks for the follow
interesting name
let's go back
always nice being up upon
control
this is a nice clump of ponds now there
is increments there's a three second
increments so I can't go for any night
dirty flags I actually have to convert
when the time is right I would like to
play f5 or just fork him or her win
material
this should provoke resignation
let's play
I'm somewhat conflicted I was about to
play nine f3
just probably a fine move I'm gonna keep
my knight there I'll play queen g2
problem is this bishop can't really
activate itself
trap the Queen can I do this
try that
pawn is attacked let's do this
just want to keep control
rook I wanted to play this in this
Queen trade
speed up a piece be up more material but
they look back on d1
work now
take here and sd-3 check
that wouldn't be losing that was close
to losing though
i pre-move that for a split second there
I'll pre move this that's a safe pre
move
about to pre-move rook c7
it's always nice in these aughts of
clara bishop positions you can just pre
move a bunch of things
question here is how do I win this put
the bishop on b4 and then maneuver the
rook
yeah let's
work on f4
Bishop's III just be extra safe
taking a long time
okay free pawn I could pull a Ben
Feingold and make what like seven
bishops would people enjoy that
okay let's just push pawns
first goal
okay I win Connect four
make seven nights I saw some absurd
picture that been Feingold posted on
Facebook of like all the pieces and even
more like extra pieces clumped together
and then there is just like king and
rook mates was really bizarre
problem is I can't like multi pre-move
you
I could get all my pieces back and set
them up on my first rank I'm not gonna
do that because my opponent resigned I
wouldn't do that anyway I was gonna make
a queen um I think I don't know anyway
good game ZL 1 2 3
what was there to learn in that game oh
yeah at the London is a good opening I
want to show one trick do I want to show
one trick this is a secret trick
which I don't think I've ever had before
but with this specific move order if
black plays a media Queen b6 there's a
trick where white plays Queen B 3 C 4
Queen C 2 and this would be a very
similar line to that variation with
Knight f6 and Knight f3 included where
black would have Bishop f5 and that
would be a good find for black but in
this specific position there is a trap
where if black plays Bishop to a5 I
believe white can just take it with the
idea that after Queen take b2 Queen take
d5 this is just better for white
this queen c1 doesn't do anything queen
take a1 there's a very strong move Queen
b5 if anyone wants to explore this line
further you can do so on me chess or you
can you can buy my London course because
I went over this line in debt there is a
game or Gelfand lost pretty brutally but
yeah it's a cool variation and trap some
pretty strong players with it so let's
move on oh my phone's on the floor now
as I wanted to I wanted it not to mess
with them like
okay
give me a random number between 1 and 13
it's 9 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 Paul good luck
Paul
how to defend against London
well if my opponent plays a London then
we'll find that it's
but is Paul around
Paul where are you
oh here's Paul okay
let's play d5 again I want to play
that I wanted to play last time
um hopefully he'll play more normally
okay this is very playable for whites I
wanted to play the Cambridge Springs but
yeah people do this these days play c6
now we have a qgd exchange variation
he's not playing the London
unfortunately let's play Bishop f5 I'll
go into this line
this is a very well-known line where we
trade Queens Black gets awkward pawn
structure but I also get the bishop pair
and I enjoy playing the slide for a win
because it has some very interesting
positional elements I'll start with 97
there's a lot of like Queen sigh light
Queen sight play ideas for black and
involving Knight b6 Knight C 4 a 5 a 4
and we'll see how he handles it
didn't you see piano play this recently
I don't know I've I have not been
following as much top-level chess as I
should be it's possible though I'm gonna
throw in Bishop e4 check I'll pre move
Knight d6 there is a really well-known
really notable game within the last
couple of years between Carlson and
Kramnik in the Sun and Carlson had some
great preparation and just
just crushed Kramnik
but I'm still happy to play this line
because most people don't have amazing
preparation like Carlson am i a fan of
the Slav
huge fan of the Slav I like the semi
Slav is there is more dynamic play I
just don't like this love because
exchange Slav kind of scares me
let's move the bishop back east seven I
was about to play Bishop d6 but in many
cases and night maneuvers to d6 via one
of these squares like if he plays b3 the
knight see it is a very common move
if he plays me through here I would
probably play a five first
one year till I graduate from miles
north 2012 I was a long time ago
as good ol days
and yeah that's true I can reach that
Cambridge Springs from a semi Slav
for the follow whatever-your-name-is
as do I play a four do I start with this
pay for it before I complained
for there and we trade stuff
h5 he would play h4
I don't know I'm
selected
I just want to see what he does next
move I'm gonna play King d7 it's just
kind of a waiting move slow improving
moves a slow improving move okay he
wants to find that f5 that's logical
gofer this maneuver
am I still using the blue Yeti
oh yeah the background noise is probably
the fan of my computer
give me one moment let me let me see how
bad this sounds
and then I stopped talking so there's no
sound
you
you
yeah for future extremes I'll use a blue
Yeti I left it at the Chess Club I don't
think it's too bad I I did a test
recording I'm using the samsung go mic
which is this thing and I have a very
small mic stand which is just a bottle
of jelly
each v is an interesting move
can i play tried myself that's playable
just trying to deflect the bishop
you
I couldn't work lift I should lift more
left
rook v6 wait there's no increment in
this game I should play quicker
good thing I have a time advantage move
the night back there's a pin put the
rook on the open file or half open file
like we barely got through like
middlegame and now he's about to flag
I'm also about to flag
leave the pond tension
so one thing when white plays e4 in
these positions
Bishop's become happier usually of the
rebec move the bishop back
ooh
little pressure
I can trade everything
okay
I'm sorry to my opponent felt like a I
don't know it was one of these like
positional middle games and he just took
too long I guess
have I spent on chess sets which one is
my favorites I'm gonna give you a very
disappointing answer I don't know what
chess sets I own I don't know if I even
own a chess set there might be something
I'm pretty sure I could like put
together like a board in pieces but I
have not put much money into chess sets
because I play mostly online I study
using the computer has anyone read the
art of learning by Waitzkin
um I recommend like I like to recommend
that book ah that's a great book just in
terms of the learning process because it
applies to so many things beyond chess
I haven't I actually haven't read the
full book but I've read like the chaste
parts of it and I can definitely vouch
for it okay where is my phone where's
Siri
give me a random number between 1 and 13
the answer is nine okay one two three
four five six seven eight
clopin good luck oppa
as clover here d4 okay I'm going to try
and try and play the same opening I want
a Cambridge Springs oh but we have a
London okay I'll play
I'll play the line that I've been
playing recently against the London
or should I go for the other line
let's go for this line first
depending what he plays
if I play knight c6 he's gonna play 92
so what I'm going to do is play a six
here
and then I will play Bishop d6 this is
probably the simplest line I can
recommend against the London move order
is very important so pay pay close
attention after Queen c7
I haven't played knight c6 if the knight
we're on c6 he could win a pawn with D
takes e5 so I keep everything defended
and I'll play Knight B d7 and the idea
is it's almost impossible for white to
stop 'if I've
so he takes to take with Knights this is
already very comfortable for black
because I have more Center pawns g5
might still come 94 might be coming
playin chess calm I was playing on chess
calm like an hour ago
trying to get my bullet rating up and
I'm probably gonna start playing these
arena kings tournaments and I think the
next season is next month
so I'll look to play that
because the sites have like their
advantages and disadvantages
I mean clearly I've been I've been more
into beach s at least recently just
because there are tools I think are are
easier to use and the study feature is
amazing I don't think just calm has
anything comparable to the study feature
unless I'm mistaken but the ability to
save collections of games and to
collaborate with other users
it just it's amazing for teaching it's
amazing for self-study and
[Music]
there's been at least for me I found
less bugs with with Li Ches but on the
other side like the the community on
Ches comm is great there's so many like
GM's always online and they have cash
tournaments on a regular basis so I'm
glad that both platforms exist because
then like the so called competition just
encourages both platforms to bring more
value to the users and I'm I'm grateful
for that
anyway 95 let's go for a 5 very soon I
did not watch neap over screech ik I
probably should have
this week is busy for me so it's hard to
like find time to watch stuff especially
alive
let's castle
so I would like to play this but then
night here so maybe I can play g6
looks weird but let's do it
z5e for even just a five-night Bishop e6
now there is two second increments so
there will be no dirty flagging boop nd
I did see the carlson 93 game I have I
did a stream like going over that game
where I had not seen the game until I
played through it on stream so forever
for anyone who watched that you would
see my um my candid reaction and it's on
youtube I think I posted it on YouTube
for two bishops two bishops of course
unless it's bullets or bughouse and
definitely two nights
in this case we both have two nights in
one Bishop but I have two Center pawns
play Bishop Bishop d7
it's concerning Bishop e6 but I want my
works in the center unobstructed
favorite chess player that's a tough
question because there's many different
factors to judge chess players on
style
karpov or michael adams
I don't know it's it's hard to gauge
he probably like Joe baba or Richard
reporter
he's about to flag plus you can start
averaging like two seconds per move this
is such a nice position though let's go
for this
or
nor him I just want to double on one of
these files probably the C file
tap the pond
this
let's go for
[Music]
this
you
I think there's some plan of king g7
rocket shades
wait what does Bishop take g6
this desperation
ooh more material for me
you
okay good game Hopa hello hello two more
people or wait no people are just saying
hi to each other
hello dirt laborat you did not miss too
much
you didn't miss this nice game this anti
London variation I think this is a
simplest thing to play I do recommend
though if they play like some early
there's another line I'd like to
recommend where you play knight c6
Knight f3 and then Queen b6 the problem
with that line is after knight c6 92 it
can lead to other sorts of positions but
in this line
I think just black just equalizes now I
will say I've studied this from the
white side a few days ago I found a
counter response but I'm not going to
show it now because I might make a
youtube video about it but there's
something very specific I can do to to
deal with this if you are a London
player
our player gets to my level hardcore
theory what's your way to get better
very small differences separating if my
level from my next level a lot of it is
consistency and just being sharp and
maintaining or like your health and your
stamina during tournaments of course
everyone's different but yeah opening
theory plays of a much larger role
especially like players my level the
tournaments we play in or playing other
strong players lose games we have access
to before we play them so most
tournaments I play I'll I'll look up all
my points before I play them and then
study their games
I need my tendencies and try and find
their the holes in their opening
repertory
do I listen to classic rock y'all they
gather wait I don't think that question
is directed at me
um I usually don't keep my opening
novelties a secret I just want the best
medium of sharing them with the world
which is not right now okay random
number time
give me a random number between 1 and 11
give me a random number between
and 11 it's five what are the holes in
my repertory
my repertoire
on the web for what are the holes in my
record okay uh one two three four five
okay good luck
I could play a London
let's just play e4 to be aggressive
playing the London as a whole I mean my
repertoire is weird because I usually
adapt like I'm capable of playing d4e
foresee for a night of three on move one
I like to adapt to what my opponents
play so I don't have like the typical
repertory that most players have but
there are some holes which I'm not going
to get into right away
I like the fact that he's thinking here
if I had to like rank my favorite
openings London would be number one this
would be number two I love this opening
it's just laced with traps and landmines
and he's already terrified a six a six
is a move I actually like to play a six
is back when I place assume the Euler
discourages Bishop c4 and then the
bishop now should develop to g2
and this is gonna be more of a
Sicilian unless there are some cases
where I play Bishop g2 92 in d4 I
transpose into some strange open
Sicilian
so he's just thinking what is he
thinking about
there's no increments
it is complicated move three
pieces still on the board
lamanna's
see you back - I have another twitch
question maybe you can help how do I
become verified on twitch I just want
like the check mark thing is there a
simple process g6
six let's buy h4
I have a tournament game recently where
my opponent played g6 on move two
the same position but without a six my
opponent played Bishop to g7 this
position I'm curious can I play d4
with Bishop g2
wait you see it am i already verified
oh I'm verified I didn't even know that
okay
verified I don't even remember going
through like the verification process
well I guess the next step is becoming
verified on are these other platforms
like Twitter
that might be more difficult
game with Korea door
in
priyadarshan the GM
are you referring to
- who are you referring to
because I have a good friend as a GM his
name is Fred arson is he challenging
on Syria dharshan here
let's continue developing
did I play 92
should have played night night h3 was
such a better move
my name is misplaced
maybe I'll go for this
each three
or it's just a more effective piece
because sometimes g5 is weak
um Manas I will not let you know when we
can play Siri will let me know when we
can play because that's that's a system
for this stream
um
d6
let's play a four
if you want to give me a shout-out on
Twitter
Lisak was a context but you have 5,000
followers
Wow
just broke like 1,000 not too long ago
okay so now the Knights on h3
you
and there's some idea here of playing
very slowly
might put the bishop on g5 Queen undo to
involves 91c 393 start with Bishop g5
he never wants to play f6
ninety-five
pressure
um yeah using Syria's not an excuse
that's what I've been doing for the last
four this dream and for many other
streams so
that's going to be the system at some
point I might change the system
not sure
that was weird
it just shows a game but from his
perspective that's interesting
yeah the thing about these positions at
least for the black side it's not least
clear what to do
the fact i provoked h5 he doesn't really
want a castle if he does castle I have
ideas of f4 f5 which I'm going for I
kind of forgot he could play f6 now but
I guess I'll have to deal with it
then they can come in to e6
should be okay
this is a little bit reckless
but I have a time
have sorry about that Mike fell off
it's very tiny stand
yeah I have a time advantage and I have
initiative
and he six outposts which he might
sacrifice a trip for
that my queen will come in
I have to play [ __ ] of h3 support the
pawn and maybe I'll go for rook f7 and
Queen h6 and rook F one
he wants to take the pawn
so let's start
a queen
effectively works
I could play 92 threatening c3 and then
I have 9 F for
yeah let's put the nine in our four
maybe I start with this
maybe I don't
so what am i down I'm down a piece
I'm down okay I have a rook for two
miners
rook and pun I've not lost upon yet
that's good
now let's
place III I want to play d4 d5
just reinforce the e6 pawn
this is nice pawn structure still
haven't lost upon
as pieces can't really do much to me now
I can start winning pawns
you
white is now better
avoid any trade
I want to win this game without losing
upon
I'm so close don't take my b2 pond
you
please don't
does he want more time I could give him
more time I gave him more time
because I want to win this game in
fashion
not going to give him too much more time
and now other nights coming to f6
take the pond
and then retreats
let's play b3
give him more time I just like this
position so much I don't want him to
flag
let's have the triple battery
but the king on g2 first
in the night here
you
yeah bring the night to g5
[Music]
I have to be careful about my own time
and this is rated too
you
and I win this
we work H one first
I think that was the last
more time I'm giving him
unless he wants more time
could trade
and then wait I want him to win g3
though
so maybe I'll take and play g4
and then king
three
what is this position I could go into f7
and then maybe this
you
what is he doing
night
you
mine is very close to trapped
take as bishop to
do this he wants a draw No
want to draw
let's play
move the rook here wait a minute where
should I move the rook
the rock here
oh he flagged cuz I forgot to give him
more time I'm so sorry
what's the valuation of this position
i takee five was an easy win
in this way in what position in this
position or in this position
you
also whose Priyadarshan
I don't quite understand
just for fun I'll discuss the stockfish
evaluation
this black human be three
clear
if I can break through on the kingside
she don't know
okay I'm guessing like plus-one
- lets just check
plus one
mmm plus two plus three
because 93
oh I just have Brooke h1 preventing
night c1 this should be too
like
I see one
yeah I think I can play h6 and then
somehow break through also my computer
is lagging so let's avoid using
stockfish
okay Siri
give me a random number between 1 and 14
give me a random number between 1 and 14
that would be nine it's always nine
who's this one two three four five six
whoops I accepted a challenge that I
didn't mean to accept I'm playing food
wine
good luck food wine I'm sorry for
whoever nine was this food mine even
here
unlike food mine is here
we'll give it
more yeah okay we're playing a game food
wine is playing quickly
playing a to Knights attack
this is a five plus 10
as food mine played like any games at
all
is this the first game ever played
played three games
okay
currently thinking
I was too late to aborts unfortunately
this is one of my favorite variations
against the French the so-called two
nights attack brawl Orion is back a low
brawler Ryan
in this variation especially with the
pawn on g4 now there's a trap I can't
play d3 because Queen 85 check I can
take and then play d3
like in castle
yeah there's probably some theory pretty
sure yes III is a main line after c5 but
this is easy to play in blitz castle III
you
yeah
those pawns are just so weak
I think there's some ID like a for
Bishop a3
maybe I'll bring my night to see for
95 you guys could have played that right
away
or
yeah you saw the van wheelie game that
was such a painful game but he's so good
at chess such a strong positional player
I play them twice in the same summer
both at these tournaments in the
Netherlands both games I was black he's
so solid as whites
you
okay this is nice
you see six I'm only seeing both my
queen and my f-pawn
I just want to be aggressive not
the plan is with queen h5 hoping
something falls into place
something involving a four
you
is it hard to go back and forth from
view to actual award when I was younger
that was probably more of an issue but
now it's there's no difference just
position is a chest position
um but that's an interesting question I
think some newer players like sometimes
it's hard to go from one to the other
night back to e8 he wants a draw
on a draw
upon storm
you
okay I think the plan is to
proved improve
be unimproved
I just want to put like all the pieces
on the kingside
something
someday I'll go for f5
you
there is something to be said like over
the board Chester's like there's more
pressure sometimes online chess when
you're just clicking away it's so it's
so much easier to get careless
okay he's doing something with his
nights
let's play rock f2 he's going to play
night before
this increment can make this game go
long
so I'll probably have to like come up
with something productive it maybe not
h5 at some point my h5 and g4 rook g2 is
one option
looks attractive the thing is if i play
my h5 here's g6
maybe I just go back
some weakness
a five is still always a resource
even like 9h four and a five
again with this position it's so hard
for black to find anything active
because there's really no pawn breaks
that makes sense for black if you ever
play z5 I play f5 so you could try f5
I play e5
already getting tired
the sky's username is making me hungry
and thirsty
g5 I can't on percent
could do this but then he does this a
mess
five this is going to be a very closed
position
it is pretty late in America coal player
are you in America or you're in Canada I
forget it's after midnight in America
I'm not gonna be around for too much
longer at least tonight
but the plan is to play gee
or queen g3 h4 hey we have an Australian
thanks for the comment crimson bovine
well players in England will play are
you going to go to the World
Championship
it's officially in London I think
I could make a dirty flag emote but I
think other chest streamers already have
dirty flag emotes
I do want to make a London emote though
I'm going to play g4 give them one night
Nathan six-round I'm in the process of
my trip
I would like to go for the whole event
but I might just go towards the end or
something
you
six he is pulling up a fight
he wants that Queen trade
now h4 is an option here if I play h4
threatening to take he would probably
take
not sure how promising that is
just want my knight to come to h5
to get to g3 to do that I need to get to
f1 okay so this is a pet but I need to
defend this pawn first
I could do this this and then this
takes a long time
I can also do this maybe and then do f6
that probably doesn't make any sense
because at that time would be pinned
you
so what to do
I can do no h3 does not seem right
okay I'm just gonna play Bishop III the
plan is to play rook c1
and then this maneuver
and if he does this I'll put my queen on
each five
it's difficult to draw
I still mess it up
miss with these lines I'm getting my
practice in
he's gonna be really annoying with his
queen he's gonna play this and I'll play
this need goes back and I go back and
then it could be a draw
there was no increment I could grind
this down
there's increments
I play Queen h3
mistake because that could allow some
future age five
you
I'm probably going to make a very bad
decision here
I want to do this but I'm going to take
the night
going to allow this
very close draw position and I'm going
to try and grind it out because this is
casual
there's no rating on the line the guy
should play a five if I want to play for
a win
you
you
I'm expecting that he's going to trade
Queens
it's so excessive 600 pounds oh for VIP
tickets that's why you have to become
friends with either of Magnus or Fabiano
upon
he's gonna wind up on
I can't really stop him
it's not good
I didn't see that far ahead
maybe I could play h4 though h4g for
their there there
doesn't work
you
wait a minute h4 g4 I've rook g2
let's do it
and try
I think mama DRL is still number three
in the world but he's close to number
two
you 700 Ches yeah mama DRI was 2817
Carlin is 28:22
you
so he plays King h6 it's logical but now
I can probably hold on I'm gonna take
and play rook h2 wait a minute or I'm
just winning e5
or am I just meeting him somehow assess
to be made somehow work h2 I'll
calculate rook h2 King g4
King off to threatening wreckage for
mates so he would take on g5 then I play
rook g1 Jack King f4 rook G to H five
and the knight h2 and he can't soccer g4
one more time rook h2 King g4 King f2
threatening wreckage for so the only way
for him to get out of it is to take then
I play rook g1
King F for
play rook g2 branding rookie for mates
you would play h5 and I play Knight each
to
rook take a five there
but no truck take a five I still made
him on g4 I think this works
Kim G Ford's only leave
No
to life
is no other movement f2
g5
I wonder if there's any other maybe
there's some simpler win
this is pretty nice this King King is
having major regrets
as h5 night h2
g4 is on the way you probably cream over
g4
wells nice
wasn't expecting to meet him so quickly
expecting a really long grind this King
was just overly active
that h2 nice finish
five Gigi
what did he do wrong yeah he walked his
King he watched his king to f4 maybe he
was overly ambitious to take the pawn
anyway that's a nice calculation okay oh
do I end it there and sleep happily or
do I accept another challenge
I think I'm gonna end it there it's been
day
anyone else dreaming
hey Manas is streaming good Rayden on us
watch streamers always have trouble
spelling his name okay good night
everyone
a feel free feel free to raid Manas or
at least join the raid and good night